FOR RIGHT GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
AND WELCOME TO THE FIRST
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OF
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING
INTERESTED IN OUR HEARING I
NEED TO MENTION A FEW TECHNICAL
AND PRACTICAL ISSUES AS WE GET
STARTED. DUE TO CONTINUED STAY
HOME WATER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. AND WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
HERE IN PERSON. WE ARE
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN.
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ANY AND ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN THIS ROOM. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN.
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. BECAUSE OF
OUR SPACE LIMITATIONS WE HAVE
SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS SITTING
ON THE DAIS AND OTHERS MAY BE
SITTING IN THE FIRST TWO ROWS.
IN THE AUDIENCE. FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING THE
HEARING PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS AND PLEASE REMEMBER
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
AND WE HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES. TODAY FOR TESTIMONY
IF YOU ARE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO WE CAN ACCOMMODATE ONLY A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
UNLIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC OR
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN THE
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL. AS
WELL AS FOR THOSE IN THE ROOM
AND IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
PARTICULAR BILL. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND WE'RE
ASKING THAT NO ONE. PLEASE
DON'T TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO COMMENT BY A TELEPHONE.
THERE IS A THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
WHICH IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO- TO I REPEAT THOSE THE
PHONE NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO-
TO THE SHOULD BE ON YOUR SCREEN
AND IF NOT THEY'LL BE ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE SO THAT YOU
CAN. CALL IN. THE HEARING TODAY
WILL BE IN FILE ORDER. AND WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
CAN START AS A SUB COMMITTEE SO
WE WILL DO THAT. FIRST UP IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO THEN A. B.
SEVEN ONE SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENEFITS. MORE IS VERY MUCH
GERMAN STILL. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF UP FOR WORKING
UP ON THIS MEASURE AND WE WILL
ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU WITH THE
PANDEMIC THAT HAS RECENTLY HIT.
THE IT HAS CHANGED AND WE ARE
AT AN INFLECTION POINT IN TERMS
OF THE WHOLE ISSUE OF PUBLIC
TRANSPARENT- THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE OF THE
UNITED STATES COURTS CAUTIONED
THAT THE COURTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY MAINTAIN PUBLIC
ACCESS- DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE HAVE INSTANCES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT
HAS NOT HAPPENED IN KERN
COUNTY. THEY PROVIDED REMOTE
ACCESS TO THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS OF A DEFENDANT IN A
CRIMINAL COURT PROCEEDING BUT
NOT TO OTHER PEOPLE. AND I
THINK THAT CERTAINLY CHALLENGES
THE APPEARANCE OF TRANSPARENCY-
IN MY OWN DISTRICT THE OHIO
VALLEY NEWS ASKED FOR A REMOTE
ACCESS AND THE COURTS TURNED
THEM DOWN- AT OPEN WATER
EDUCATION HEARING. AND IT WOULD
FORCE- A SMALL NEWSPAPER TRYING
TO COVER SOMETHING IMPORTANT TO
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY TRAVEL
ALL THE WAY TO LOS ANGELES BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY EXPOSE
THEMSELVES TO THE VIRUS AT THE
PEAK OF THE PANDEMIC TIME
PERIOD. IN A CLOSED COURTROOM.
AND THE COURTS SAID YOU HAVE
ACT IF YOU WANT TO COME. SO OF
THE POPE IT IS NOT OVER WILL BE
THE TIME. THAT WE WILL THIS OF
OUT THERE TO AB ONE SIX
REQUIRES THAT- THE COURTS WHERE
IT IS FEASIBLE WHERE THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE EQUIPMENT-
OPEN THEMSELVES UP AND PROVIDE-
THE ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC VIA
INTERNET OR TELEPHONE SERVICE.
AND THAT WOULD MODERNIZE OUR
COURT SYSTEM AND SHOULD BRING
US INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ALL BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY. IT WOULD JUST
INCREASED PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY.
IN GENERAL I HAVE JUST TWO
REFLECTIONS AS I BRING MY
COMMENTS TO AMANDA. ONE IS THAT.
IN GENERAL MY TIME MOST ORGAN.
ARE NOT TENANTS. TO DECREASE
PAUL ACTS AND HAVE TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF REQUIREMENTS FOR. OR
ELSE YOU SAW IN THIS SITUATION
IN A PANDEMIC WHERE THE COURTS
TOOK ADVANTAGE I SHOULD SAY
TAKE ADVANTAGE BUT THEY JUST
CHANGE THEIR PROCEDURES AND
DECREASED. WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
EMPHASIS ON PUBLIC ACCESS ALSO
WE HAVE THIS QUESTION ABOUT
VIDEO ACCESS ALSO IT'S A VERY
LEGITIMATE QUESTION. BUT I
THINK IF IT FALLS INTO THE
NATURE OF A LARGER CONVERSATION
ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW VIDEO
RECORDINGS IN THE COURT ROOM
LIFE. BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IF WE SIT THERE AND SAY
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW REMOTE
ACCESS. THE COURT SYSTEM LOSES
CONTROL DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
TO HAVE A BAN ON LIVE
RECORDINGS IN THE COURT ROOM IF
WE'RE TURNING AROUND AND-
ALLOWING ANYBODY TO COPY A LIVE
RECORDING THERE SO THAT'S A
LARGER QUESTION. AND I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS
BILL MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS-
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES-
AS THEY COME UP. SO WITH THAT-
THE IS A I THINK IN A POOR TIME
I URGE A YES I VOTE FOR THIS
MAY THING YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MR BY. BEFORE WE TO WITH.
OPERATOR YOU CAN MAIL THE LINES
FOR B. SEVEN ONE SIX RIGHT NOW.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO I'D LIKE
TO CALL THE COURT STONE HERE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU DAVIES AND
SALAS PRESIDENT HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. EIGHT
SO FOR AB SEVEN ONE SIX I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ELLEN
NOBLE. PUBLIC JUSTICE AND
BRITNEY FOR SAUDI OF CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION.
THIS NOBLE. YES THANK YOU-
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIXTEEN I'M ELLEN NOBLE
AN ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC DROPPED
IT PUBLIC CHUCK THIS IS THAT
NATIONAL PUBLIC INTEREST
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT
SPECIALIZES IN PRECEDENT
SETTING SOCIALLY SIGNIFICANT
CIVIL LITIGATION. THANK TO OUR
MISSION IS ON TO JUSTICE FOR
WORK CONSUME AND OTHERS BY
CORPORATE AND GOVERNMENT
WRONGDOING. IN THAT EFFORT
TRUST IS HEADED PROJECT TO
COMBATING COURT SECRETLY AND
DEFENDING PUBLIC AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO ACCESS AND OBSERVE
JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS. WE
BELIEVE THAT JUSTICE SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE AND
THAT PUBLIC ACCESS TO COURT
PROCEEDINGS IS CRUCIAL TO
ENHANCING THE FAIRNESS THE
PRECEDING ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BUILDING
PUBLIC TRUST IN THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS. THE COBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CODES A FUNDAMENTAL
THREAT TO THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT OF
ACCESS. I'M COURTHOUSES
TEMPORARILY CLOSED WHILE OTHERS
HAD TO BE REALLY LIMIT IN AT
THAT COMPLY SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDE. ON TOP OF THAT MA'AM OF
THE WORD BY NOT TRAVEL. TO USE
PUBLIC. OR TIME EVEN WE THEIR
HOME. SO PROMOTE OF THE TRIP OF
A JUST LOOKING POSSIBLE.
INTEREST MANY DON'T NOT ALL
COURT QUICKLY ADAPTED USING A
TECH. TO A RUN PUBLIC ACCESS TO
CRIMINAL CIVIL PROCEEDINGS.
UNDER THE PROPOSED L. A. SEVEN
SIXTEEN ALL CALIFORNIA TO BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THAT SAME
REMOTE. AND THE PA FIRST MEMBER
RIGHT ABOUT THAT. HE DID ON
MAKE AND FUTURE THREATS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. THAT
MAY ALSO IMPORTS ACT THE POOR.
ABC SIXTEEN WITHOUT SEEK THE
PUBLIC'S OF ACCESS. EVEN WHEN
WE'RE NOT A TO NOT CRIED. THE
BILL RECOGNIZES THAT THE
DIFFICULT OR IN A OF TO THE
CORE. AND INTENDING IN BECAUSE-
IT IS SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE. EVEN WHEN WE'RE NOT IN
A CAN. BUT REQUIRING REMOTE ACT
TO CORPORATE THE AND TO IN
PERSON AT THAT. EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTEEN MAKE THE COURT. MORE
ACCEPTABLE TO EVERY. PUBLIC THE
SPRING PALFFY ON BEHALF OF
LOCAL. IT LANDED BEEN- WORKERS
WORKING TREATED ON. AND YOU CAN
YOU KNOW AREN'T JUDICIAL.
INTERNET ACCESS JUDICIAL
PROCESS THAT DIRECT IMPACT
THEIR LIFE. THAT PUBLIC ACCESS
EMPOWERS INTO IN THE PROCESS
WHICH PROTECT AND STRENGTH OUR
TO MY- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OP TO IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX. AND
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO PUT PARKED EVEN THE
CALIFORNIA NEW PUBLIC THAT.
THANK YOU. BERNIE VERSACE
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE I MY NAME IS
FOR A OUR SONG AND I'M AND OF
AB SEVEN SIX ON THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC MISCONCEIVED- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE
THE NOTED ON. BOTH THE BASIC
FAIRNESS OF THE PROCEEDINGS AND
THE APPEARANCE OF FAIRNESS SO
ESSENTIAL TO THE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM- IT
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT REMOTE
ACCESS IS NOT MEANT TO BE AND
MILLION OF. PHYSICAL ACCESS ON
BASED ON THE NUMBER TAKEN AND
WE RESPECTFULLY- TRACK OUT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU NOW GOING OPEN
IT UP FOR ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN ONE SIX
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SO TESTIFY. ALL RIGHT NOW.
I'M GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR THE
PHONE LINES FOR FOLKS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. AND REMIND THOSE ON THE
LINE THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING
FURTHER TESTIMONY AT THIS
POINT. SO IF YOU JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
OPERATOR. ARE THERE ANY CALLERS
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. CALIPHATE WE
HAVE ABOUT TWO PEOPLE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIBBY SANFORD
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AS AMENDED. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION WE DO LIKE
THE BILL- AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
REFLECTED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AT THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR I'M GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NONE LISTED.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- NOTE OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
OPEN ALLIANCE FOR OPPOSITION
FOR A. B. SEVEN ONE SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEIR- NOW. THE MATERIALS THAT
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
THEN YOU MAY CLOSE THE PHONE
LINES FOR A. B. SEVEN ONE SIX.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THE REST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THIS
BILL IS A REALLY GOOD FIRST
STEP I- ACCESSIBILITY TO
RECORDS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS TIME OF CRISIS- WELL WE'RE
SLOWLY STARTING TO RE OPEN IT
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
SAFEGUARDS- AND I APPRECIATE
THE BILL IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL- AND I REALLY HOPE THAT
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE.
EXPRESSED CONCERNS OVER THE
BILL WILL WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE- TO RESOLVE
THESE. I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION-
AND I THINK YOU ANSWERED THIS
IN YOUR STATEMENT BUT I WANTED
TO JUST REITERATED IF I MAY.
THAT I SAW ON THE ANALYSIS OF A
COUPLE OF ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE ACLU. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. ARE NOT OPPOSED
BUT DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL DO YOU INTEND TO WORK WITH
THESE GROUPS TO RESOLVE THEIR
CONCERNS. YES I. DO HI- INTEND
TO WORK WITH THE MY POINT OUT
THAT. THEY HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE CONCERNED OUR OFFICE OF
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE OF
CONCERNED ABOUT OPENING UP
VIDEO ACCESS ACLU IS REQUESTING
VIDEO ACCESS. ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE TO SQUARE THAT CIRCLE
BUT- I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM AND AS I POINTED OUT
OF MY COMMENTS WE HAVE THE
LARGER QUESTION I THINK OF
WHETHER. VIDEO RECORDINGS WILL
BE ALLOWED IN LIVE COURT
PROCEEDINGS AND HOW WOULD WE BE
PUTTING SOMETHING ON LINE WITH
WITH WITH YOUR ALSO AUDIO
RECORDINGS ARE NOT ALLOWED AT
THIS POINT TIME AND WE WOULD BE
PUTTING THIS ON LINE- BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY MUCH MORE CHALLENGING
FOR THE COURTS TO POLICE VIDEO
RECORDINGS- IF THEY- ARE POSTED
ONLINE. RATHER THAN. LIVE
RECORDINGS OF THE CORPORATE SO
WE WILL WORK WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND I'M I WOULD
LIKE TO COMPLIMENT ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS WE WORK WITH A I
THINK HAVE FAVORABLY APPROACH
THIS ISSUE AND ARE TRYING TO
WORK OUT THESE ISSUES WITH US
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. MR GALLAGHER. YEAH THANK
YOU SO A MEMBER- PRECIADO BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD I ALSO- SHARE
THE SUPPORT FOR TRANSPARENCY
YOU KNOW AND ENSURING THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS- TO COURT
PROCEEDINGS- THE QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE IS- YOU KNOW WITH THAT I
KNOW THERE ARE THERE CAN BE
SENSITIVE- PROCEEDINGS IN A
COURT DATE FOR THAT THE FOR
SOME REASON YOU MAY NOT WANT TO
MAYBE INVOLVING MINORS OR-
OTHER THINGS- DOES. HAVE YOU
TALKED TO SOME OF THE- YOU
KNOW. VICTIMS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
GROUPS PERHAPS ABOUT ANY OF
THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES. THAT ARE
PLANS TO KIND OF HELP ADDRESS
THAT AT ALL OR- WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANY EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS IN
THE REGION IS- WE ONLY JUST
CHANGED THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC ACCESS SO WHEN ALL OF
THE SAME PROCEEDINGS WHERE. THE
JUDGE DECIDES THAT HE WANTS TO
CLOSE THOSE DOWN TO PROTECT THE
VICTIM TO FOR WHATEVER REASON
THEM YES THIS ACCESS WILL ALSO
BE CLOSED UP TO WHEN THE PUBLIC
IS ALLOWED. THIS INTERNET
ACCESS WOULD BE ALLOWED ON THE
PUBLIC'S NOT ALLOWED THIS
INTERNET ACCESS WITH PEOPLE
OKAY AND THEN HAVE YOU TALKED
WITH- THANK IN THE JUDGE'S
GROUPS YET AMERICA YESTERDAY
OPINED ON ANYTHING WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL
FROM THE BEGINNING OKAY AND
THEY'VE RAISE ONE ISSUE AND
THAT IS HOW MUCH TECHNOLOGY DO
THEY HAVE AN EXISTING- DO ALL
OF THE ROOMS HAVE TO HAVE THIS
SIX BEDROOM. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM- ON THAT BUT
CERTAINLY ALL OF THE ROOMS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE. IT OUGHT TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE. OKAY THANK
YOU SOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS FROM THE DIE.
STATE. THIS IS A DEVELOPING
STORY NOW SEE A SPECIALIST
PROVISION SEVENTY ANALYZE THE.
SO- SIX ONE PROGRAMS ON FOR A.
THANK YOU SOMETIME COVERED
OPENS UP OUR EYES WE RELY THIS
IS A THAT WOULD PROBABLY COULD
BE DOING IN THE PAST I THINK
IT'S A GREAT FEELING THANK YOU.
THE RESEARCH OUT. OF I LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. NOT LONG AGO. A
COMMITTEE HAS A HEARING ON ON.
THE IMPACT OF A COVER NAY. ON
CLOSEST. I THINK ONE OF THEM
THINGS GO WILL BROUGHT UP WITH
THE REMOTE ACCESS. TO THIS IS A
VERY. BILL I THINK YOU ALSO
TOUCHED ON THE- YOU KNOW THE-
THAT YOU BEEN DOING WITH THE-
CARE. I THINK ONE OF THE-
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO ALSO-
LOOK AT IS THE FUNDING. YOU
KNOW IF THEY NEED THE FUNDING
FOR THE REMOTE ACCESS I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
IT AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WITHOUT. I'M OF THE BILL.
I'M NOT CRITICAL MOTION JUST
YET BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT A- THE
RULE. SO ONCE WERE. DONE WITH
BILL BEFORE I TAKE A MOTION. WE
WILL DO THAT NEXT. RIGHT OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. SEEING
NONE THIS EVENT YOU MAY CLOSE.
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
INTERESTED. IN THE COMMENTS
JUST AS- YOU POINT OUT THAT
THIS WE ARE AT AN INFLECTION
POINT I DON'T THINK THIS WILL
BE THE LAST CHANGE IT WILL COME
ABOUT AS A RESULT OF COPING. SO
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST THANK YOU.
RIGHT BEFORE I TAKE A MOTION
LET'S ESTABLISH THE COMMITTEE
RULES WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER ONE.
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
COMMITTEE RULES. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER NOW GALLAGHER NO CHAO
CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI RES I. SIX
WE HAVE THE SIX FOOT SIX ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO THE RULES
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED ALL NIGHT NOW
TAKE A MOTION ON EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE SIX. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE HI STONE I GALLAGHER. AYE
GALLAGHER AYE CHAU. CHOW I CHIU
DAVIES. DAVIES I CONSOLIDATE.
CONSOLES I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI
REYES AT. RIGHT NOW THE BILL IS
OUT I WILL NOW TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA I WILL NOTE
THAT I'VE NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO
SIXTY STONE HAS BEEN MOVED TO
THE PROPOSED CONSENT AGENDA
TAKE A MOTION CONSENT OF THIS
AND SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO. ALL
RIGHT THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON CONSENT. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE CHAU
CHOW I CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE READ THE CONSENT
AGENDA IS ADOPTED THAT IS RIGHT
AB TWO SIXTY STONE AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN VALLADARES AB TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN CORK AB TWO NINETY THREE
KALRA AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
OUR QUE HAN AB FOUR TO TWENTY
NINE DALY AB FOUR SEVENTY THREE
CHAU HE BEFORE SEVENTY FOUR
CHAU AB SIX ELEVEN QUICK SILVA.
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN WALDRON SB
SIX THIRTY THREE CALDERON AB
EIGHT NINETY ONE CUNNINGHAM AB
NINE THIRTY EIGHT DAVIES AB
TWELVE AWAIT TANG ED ACR TWENTY
FOUR BY MR CHILD. THANK YOU ALL.
S. WE'RE GOING IN FILE ORDER I
DO NOT SEE MR LEVINE RESTAURANT
MOST WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON AND THANK YOU FOR IS
OFTEN PRESENT AB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE. THIS BILL IS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IT WOULD ESTABLISH FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY A BRANCH
OF CALIFORNIA TO HONOR
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS A PAID HOLIDAY. WITHOUT
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF PAID
COURT HOLIDAYS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE STATE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- PERSONNEL ARE COVERED
UNDER A SEPARATE CODE SECTION
FROM OTHER STATE WORKERS
SECTION ONE THREE FIVE OF THE
CODE. OF CIVIL PROCEDURE I
THINK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THANK YOU CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY IS ALREADY
A STATE HOLIDAY IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT AYE LOBBY DOWN.
ASSEMBLY MEBER JOE BACA TO IN.
AB NINETEEN THREE THAT WAS SIDE
INTO LAW BY THEN GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON. BUT CAN DESIGNATE THE
FOURTH FRIDAY OF SEPTEMBER AS
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS ARBITRARY HOLIDAY BUT ON
PAGE THIS WILL MOVE FORWARD TO
CREATE THAT PAID HOLIDAY. FOR
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS I'VE
WORKED TOWARDS CREATING A PAID
STATE HOLIDAY RECOGNIZING AND
LEARNING ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE. TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS ON TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIKE
THE MANY ROWS THAT WE TRAVEL ON
WERE OLD INDIAN TRAILS THAT ARE
NOW PAVED IN THE HIGHWAYS THAT
WE TRAVEL ON. IN MY DISTRICT IN
REDLANDS THE INDIAN PEOPLE DUG
A DITCH THAT BROUGHT WATER INTO
THE CITY OF REDLANDS THAT THEN
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
FLOURISHED THESE ARE SOME OF
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT. DURING THIS TIME
I WANT TO THANK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FOR BRINGING THIS
PROPOSAL FORWARD BECAUSE FEW
CALIFORNIA'S KNOW MUCH ABOUT
THE STATE'S NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CULTURE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT OUR STATE. IS HOME TO
MORE THAN NAY MORE NATIVE
AMERICANS THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION THIS BILL WILL BE
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS CREW
CORRECTING THAT OMISSION. I ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO APPROVE- BABY
FIFTY FIFTY FIVE AND GRANTED
CAL. RIGHT TO MAKE THIS CHANGE
JOINING ME TODAY ARE MONTEREY
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
MARLA OLE ANDERSON. AND CHAIR
OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE. ON THE
SECOND IS CHRIS REID CHAIRMAN
CHRIS WRIGHT OF THE DRY CREEK
RANCHERIA BAND OF POMO INDIANS.
I THANK YOU SO- BREEDER YOU CAN
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR AB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AS WE MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE FIRST
WITNESSES JUDGE ANDERSON THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THEN CHRIS
RATE FROM THE DRY CREEK.
RANCHERIA BAND OF POMO INDIANS
JUDGE ANDERSON. AND GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DOWN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU AND YES I AM I CHAIRED THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY FIVE WHICH
DESIGNATES NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS THE JUDICIAL HOLIDAY. IN
LIEU OF COLUMBUS DAY. BY
RECOGNIZING NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS A JUDICIAL HOLIDAY AB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE FURTHERS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL COMMISSION. TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO ACCESS
INTERNET BY BEING RESPONSIVE TO
THE STATE'S CULTURAL AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY.EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE ALIGNS THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WITH THE OTHER BRANCHES OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT. USUAL
BRANCH HOLIDAYS ARE SET
STATUTES THE COURT TO THE ONLY
PART OF STATE GOVERNMENT THAT
STILL CLOSED ITS DOORS IN
OBSERVANCE OF COLUMBUS DAY.
WHEN THE STATE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A STATE HOLIDAY BUT THE
COURTS LIKE OTHER STATE OFFICES
WILL BE CLOSED FOR BUSINESS ON
THE SECOND MONDAY IN OCTOBER.
THANKS CHANGING MADE OF
AMERICAN DAY FOR COLUMBUS DAY
THE COURTS WILL MAINTAIN THE
SAME NUMBER OF JUDICIAL
HOLIDAYS. MISSION SHARES THE
SAME LEVEL OF ACCESS TO THE
COURTS. WHILE ALSO RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS AND
NATIVE AMERICANS TO CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER RIGHT. MISTER
RIGHT CHRIS WRITER YOU WITH US.
THE NATIONAL ON THE PHONE
ACTUALLY POSED TO BE IN PERSON.
OKAY HIS MISTER RIGHT I DON'T
SEE MISTER RIGHT IN THE ROOM
THOUGH. IS HE PERHAPS IN THE
WITNESS. VIDEO ROOM. OKAY
NOBODY'S IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM RIGHT OPERATOR WILL MOVE
THEN TO. OTHER THESE WHO WISH
TO SUPPORT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE THOSE WHO RUN
THE PHONE. PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
NAME. AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER OKAY SHE BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AND OTHER TIMES THE CHAIR NO
ONE IS SHOWING UP. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE LISTED OPERATOR YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO MIGHT
BE OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND TAKE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR NO ONE IS
CHEWING UP. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES FOR A BE A FIFTY FIVE IN
A ROW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING THIS ROOM. NO
QUESTIONS JUST ORIGINATION OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING
THIS LONG OVERDUE MEASURE
BEFORE US TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY BUT A SURVEY IN THE
STATE AND GREAT PRIDE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO PROVIDE A LIVE
UP. THANK HI. THIS IS US I ALSO
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU YOU KNOW
EVERY TIME YOUR BILLS COME
FORWARD I I'M REMINDED HOW
IMPORTANT REPRESENTATION IS.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST A ONE OFF
BILL IT IS A COME DEEP
COMMITMENT TO YOUR COMMUNITY
AND- TO CALIFORNIA TO WRITING A
LOT OF WRONG SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS AGAIN I MEAN IT'S JUST A
LITANY. OF CONSTANT REMINDER
HOW WE HAVE TO HAVE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT SO
THANK YOU. ISRAEL'S TOOK THE
WORDS RIGHT OUT OF MY MOUTH
ABSOLUTELY REPRESENTATION
MATTERS AS THE FIRST NATIVE
AMERICANS HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE YOUR BILLS HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE IT MAKES US
ALL REMEMBER THAT WE HAVE TO
REALLY THINK HISTORY WE'VE BEEN
TAUGHT A PARTICULAR WAY AND
MANY TIMES IT'S BEEN INCORRECT
AND WE- HONOR PEOPLE WHO WE
PRESUME HAD A LEGACY OF A
PARTICULAR WAY AND WE LEARNED
THAT HISTORY WAS INCORRECT AND
THAT IS VERY SPECIFIC WITH
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS- AND I'M
GLAD TO THAT THAT YOU ARE
PRESENTING THIS BILL AND THE
TWO WERE REMINDING US OF THE
TRUE HISTORY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMON
RIGHT SEEING NONE SARAMA TO
MAKE CLOTHES THANK THANK YOU
MISTER TRAGICALLY MEMBERS FOR
THOSE KIND WORDS I JUST
RESPECTFULLY- REQUEST AT THIS
TIME- ANY CO AUTHORS FROM THE
COMMITTEE COULD BE ADDED ON AND
ALSO FOR I VOTE FOR THIS
HISTORIC CHANGE AN HONOREE THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU SO
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
AND THAT MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COLLATERAL
PLACE. DON'T BUY STONE I
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE CHAU.
CHOW I CHIU. DAVIES DAVID HI
GONZALEZ CONSULT I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES FIVE
REYES AYE. THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT BRINGS US TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWO ONE
EIGHT MR WARD. L. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ACCORDING TO A RECENT SURVEY OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS IN THE
US ONLY 11% OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED THAT THEIR IDENTITY I
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS. MATCH THEIR
PREFERRED NAME AND GENDER
IDENTITY POSSESSING ACCURATE
AND CONSISTENT IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS IS ESSENTIAL BASIC
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC FUNCTIONING
IT FOR MANY TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
OBTAINING VITAL DOCUMENTS THAT
MATCH THEIR GENDER IS A MAJOR
HURDLE. WHENEVER TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCONGRUENT
IDENTIFICATION DOCUMENTS MUST
PRODUCE THEM THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY REVEALING
THEMSELVES AS TRANSGENDER EACH
OF THESE OUTINGS CAN LEAD TO
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS RANGING FROM BEING
HARASSED OR DENIED SERVICES TO
BEING PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA TRANCE-
TRANSGENDER CALIFORNIANS CAN
PETITION THE COURTS TO CHANGE
THEIR NAME AND GENDER TO
CONFORM TO THEIR IDENTITY THE
OPRAH CERTIFICATE IS SEALED A
NEW BIRTH CERTIFICATE IS ISSUED
AS AN ORIGINAL TO PROTECT BOTH
THE PERSON'S PRIVACY AND
RESPECT OUR IDENTITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT THE
CASE WHEN TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS SEEK TO CHANGE TO
CHANGE THEIR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE OR THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
IN THE EVENT OF THE NAME OR
GENDER CHANGE THE OLD
CERTIFICATES ARE ATTACHED ANY
INCORRECT LEGAL NAME IS STILL
LISTED NEXT TO THE CURRENT
LEGAL NAME AB TWO ONE EIGHT
SIMPLY ALIGNS THE PROCESS FOR
UPDATING TRANSCEND AMERISUR
DIFFICULT. AND THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THE PROCESS ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR UPDATING THEIR OWN
BITH TICKETS. THIS GETS INTO
THE- CLEAN. TO OBTAIN
IDENTIFICATION DOCUMENTS THEM
SO AND IT. PROTECTING THE
PRIVACY THERE WILL. THIS BILLS
THE MICHAEL CALIFORNIA THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA. ASKS ME NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SO CALLED SOCIAL
WORKERS AND OTHERS ON THE LINE
TODAY WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. AND
ALL FAMILY LEGAL TO- TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU THIS IS AB TWO
ONE EIGHT WE HAVE I HAVE TO
SUPPORTERS LISTED. YOUR HUSBAND
BUSH FROM ALL FAMILY LEGAL AND
TAMMY MARTIN FROM A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA. MS HOUSING BUSH.
GETTING OUT OF HERE. SH SH I
THINK WE MIGHT PUT UP THE ORDER
THAT'S ALREADY AND SOME CANYON
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY TWO ANY- AND ALL THE
BRIEFS ANIMAL. MY GO INTO
EXPLAINED VERY REAL. THE THIS
BILL HAVE A PEOPLE BUYING- AND
I IMPACT BORN OUTBY THE AS AS
AUTHORED. ONLY A SMALL FRACTION
OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE HAVE
THEIR CORRECT NAME AND GENDER
LISTED ON ALL OF THEIR IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS. WE KNOW THAT OVER
ONE THIRD OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HARASSED OR ASSAULTED
ORGANIZED SURVEY OR ASKED TO
LEAVE SOMEPLACE SIMPLY FOR
PREVENTING AN IDENTITY DOCUMENT
LISTING THE NEIGHBOR GENDER
THAT. DID NOT MATCH THEIR
GENDER PRESENTATION SO WE
DEFINITELY HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO. AND THAT'S BUILDING
IMPORTANT THAT FOLLOWING BUT
THAT'S THE FOR EXAMPLE THE
GENDER RECOGNITION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- I SENATOR
NOW PRO TEN TWENTY ATKINS.
AMONG OTHER LAWS THAT LAID A
FOUNDATION FOR ACCURATE AND
AFFIRMING IDENTITY DOCUMENT FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS THE WORST
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARWICKSHIRE PRESSING
AHEAD ON THIS ISSUE. AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AS
WELL THANK. YOU RIGHT THEY YOU
AMERICA HASN'T. MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR ME HERE MY NAME
IS IN YOUR HEAD ON CRASH AND
THEY WERE HELLO ON THE AND BUT
FOR ON ELDER BECAME THE AND
FAMILIES A PART OF THAT
PRACTICE I THINK TRANSGENDER
CLAY INTENDING WITH ONLY AND
GENDER. OKAY FIVE ENOUGH YOU
WORKING THE WILLIAMS WHICH IS
ALSO THE JURY CENTER AT OF LAW
WHITER AND TECH POTENTIAL BILL
THE MODEL AND OF YOUNG
COMMUNITY. FOR BRINGING A THAT
THE I WORKED THE CLIMATE GOING
TO AN DIVORCE SHE HAD PICK BACK
MINI AND BOTH SHE AND HER
AGREED TYPE AND THEIR CHILD
BOXING THE PERSONAL HORMONE GOT
IF SHE COULD NOT OR CHILD INTO
TRUMP FACTOR HOW JOHN SHE HAD
TRUMP. TO MAIL BETWEEN THE
BIRTH OF THEIR FIRST IMPACT
CHILD. ALL I COULD HELP HER
THAT IT WOULD COST MORE AND I
COULDN'T GET INTO THE- THEY
CHOSE NOT TO MAKE THE CHANGE AT
ALL AND HE TOLD AT THE CHILD
MOTHER ON THE WHICH. TENSION
THE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE PRIVATE
COUNSEL TO COMPLETE THEIR NAME
AND GENDER CHANGE PAPERWORK AND
I HONESTLY DON'T THINK AMERICA
SHOULD HAVE COMMANDED CLICK TO
CONTINUE WITHOUT THE OBSTACLE-
STRICTLY LOOKING SURE I CAN DO
IT AND I'M NOT SURE EVERYWHERE
WE GET THE SAME OUTCOME. IN THE
LAST YEAR WE'VE COME TO
APPRECIATE HOW VITAL ACTIVE
HOSPITALS AND THE DIAGNOSTICS
LAKLAND BASS. NO ONE WANTS TO
BE A NIGHT TIME WITH A CHILDISH.
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE- AND ADDING
THE EXTRA COMPLICATION OF A
FUNNY LOOKING. CERTIFICATE
AMERICA TO IT WOULD AMENDMENTS
IN TWO PAGES. COMPLETED AT THE
END OF CONNECTION AT WORST.
THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE. FAT ONE
VERY BY ALLOWING WHICH- VACUUM.
AFTER REFLECT TRANSITION PEOPLE.
AND GENDERS WITH HAVING TO.
TRANSACTION BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR LINK. ONLY AND GENDER.
YOUR ON ALL OF. NEST DR. NOT
THE PERFECT. THE BILL WOULD DO
TO. THAT. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SIR HERE IN THE HERE ROOM
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SO. OF A
TWO ONE EIGHT. RIGHTS NONE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINES THOSE WHO'D TO GIVE US
THEIR NAMES THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE. RIGHT
THANK YOU AND REMIND MY NUMBER
ONE REMINDERS TO THOSE IN QUEUE
ETIQUETTE NAME AFFILIATION AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING IMPACTS
FROM THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS CALLS FOR US
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
pFROM THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF COURSE WORKERS AT THAT MUCH
BEFORE WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ONE EIGHT.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR COULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR A POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME OF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES FOR A B.
TWO ONE EIGHT. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT SEEING NONE THE
STORE TO MAKE CLOSE. WE ALREADY
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU MOTION AND
THE SECOND IS TO PASS TO HEALTH
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
HI GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
CHOW CHAO II CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES NOW GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES FIVE RESIDE. SIX THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU MUST WORK
THANK YOU RIGHT MISTER LAVIGNE
OF TWO ITEMS ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN AND ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. NINE THIRTY.
GIVE A PREFERENCE FOR ORDER.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL START THAN
WITHOUT HIM HE- AB EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN. THE BILL. THANK YOU YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE COURT
FACILITIES THAT PROCESS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS AND TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS TO ALLOW
PETITIONS TO BE FILED
ELECTRONICALLY. DURING AND
AFTER NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS NO
LATER THAN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE STATEWIDE SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDERS DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN HAVE IMPACTED ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO OFTEN
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO BE
CONFINED. WITH THEIR ABUSER FOR
VICTIMS THE PROCESS THE C. A.
T. RO OR DVR- IT'S BEEN
COMPLICATED BY THE CLOSURE OF
OUR LIMITED ACCESS TO THE
COURTS AND DURING THE PANDEMIC
TIMELY ACCESS TO COURTS AS
NECESSARY NECESSARY TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
PREVENT HARM TO VICTIMS. OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ONLY THIRTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ALREADY PROVIDE
THE SERVICE AND WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LYNNE STEWART FROM
CHANGE FOR JUSTICE AND KRISTEN
IN CHECK FROM CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE STORE. GERMANTOWN
A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. ENCOURAGING YOU
IN SO MANY WAYS TO VOTE YES FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN IN
SUPPORT- IF THE PROVIDED
IMPORTANT ACTION TO ENSURE SAFE
ACCESS TO THE COURTS. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN LONG
OVERDUE BUT CERTAINLY COLLUDED
DURING THE PANDEMIC ONLY
MORE THAN A DECADE AGO I
APPLIED FOR A RESTRAINING ORDER
OR A TEMPLATE JAIL AND AT THE
TIME I WAS A REPORTER IN IF I'M
DOING A STORY ON ANY AND ALL OF
YOU I KEEP DIG IN AND FIND.
EVERY BIT OF PUBLIC INFORMATION
ABOUT EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
BUT WHEN IT CAME TIME FOR ME TO
TRY TO FIND. JEFF HOW TO FILE
IT HERE- AND EVEN WORK IN THE
LOGISTICS. I WAS OVERWHELMED
AND CHALLENGED AND I HAVE TO
SAY THAT MORE THAN A DECADE
LATER THAT PROCESS HAS NOT
IMPROVED VERY MUCH IN FACT I
CHALLENGE EACH OF YOU TO GO BY
ANY COUNTY AND TRY TO FIND
ONLINE. THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU NEED TO FILE. AN APPEAL
RIGHT EASY TO FILE AND JUST TRY
TO DO IT YOURSELF BINDING
INFORMATION. ALONE IS A
CHALLENGE. AND WHEN YOU ADD
THAT TO THE EVEN IN THE BOX HI
I WAS WORKING AT A FULL TIME
MOM. I WAS ALSO TRY TO KEEP MY
LIFE TOGETHER I HAD BE ABLE TO
FIND PARKING WHICH IS A
CHALLENGE AT THE COURT HOUSE TO
PAY FOR IT BUT THE PART. AND TO
BE ABLE TO BUY JUST CALM WHEN I
COULD GO AND FILE KNOWING THAT
I WOULDN'T HAVE GO BACK AGAIN.
THOSE DELAYS FOR MAINTENANCE
MONTH OF NOT FILING THE TIARA
WHEN I NEEDED THAT. THANKS
AGAIN. THAT'S EVEN WORSE YOU
LOOK AT MOST OF. BY DID THEM
AND- EIGHT OF THEM SELF RECORD
ENJOY HAVE THE RE. FOR THE NO
THAT I HAD. A LOT YET PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THIS COUNTRY IN.
RIGHT NOW SHE TO GO TO THE
LEGIT OF THIS THE MIDDLE OF THE
PAN. IT'S REALLY A CHALLENGE
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS IT BEARS OUT THAT THERE
IS EXPERIENCE PROBLEMS. DURING
THE WORST TIME OF THE PANDEMIC
WHEN THE COURTS ARE CLOSE. EVEN
THOUGH WE ALL KNOW THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CERTAINLY DID
NOT DECREASE. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE FILING HEROES WE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY IN MANY COUNTY. SO
CERTAINLY WE CAN'T EXACTLY WHY
THAT EITHER THERE. WAS A LACK
OF ACCESS. BUT PERCEPTION THAT
THE COURT WEREN'T OPEN THE
PEOPLE HI. SUCH AND SHE MADE TO
BE ABLE TO. LIKE PETITION AT
THE MET VIOLENCE PROTECT ORDERS.
OUR SYSTEM HAS TO DO TO THE NEW.
AND DISNEY HAS BEEN INTO. FOR
ME MANY YEARS BUT JUST NOT
RECOGNIZED BECAUSE- PEOPLE JUST
LIKE PEOPLE HAD ACCESS EVEN
WHEN THEY DIDN'T. THIS IS A
LIFE AND DEATH SITUATION THIS
ISN'T JUST A CONVENIENT ISSUE.
I CAN TELL YOU TODAY I WOULD
NOT BE HERE IN ONLY MY SIDE
WITHOUT A PROTECTIVE ORDER WE
ALL KNOW IT'S NOT A CURE ALL.
FOR SHORT. BUT IT HELD MY EXIT
IT CHECK. I'M NOT TO KEEP US
ALIVE. I'M NOT ASKING YOUR
SEATS. TO ELIMINATE THE HURDLE.
PERSPECTIVES NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN OUR CHALLENGE IN SPECIALLY
DURING CODE BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE
LOCKED INSIDE WITH THE ABUSE
THEY HAVE LESS RESTORE. BUT
JUST AS A GOING TO IN WHEN CO
IN I FOR YOUR SUPPORT. YES I
NEED TO DROP A PLEASE. NO
PROBLEM AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THREE MOVIES HURDLES
THAT TO ACTUALLY SAVE LIVES AND
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS WAS. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN PRESENTS COMMITTEE AND
IT'S KRISTIN IMPACT WITH THE
TOP PARTNERSHIPS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. I REALLY WANT TO-
FELLOW NOT FOR SHARING STORY.
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT ACT OF TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORDER. CAN BE-
OF HOW AND OTHER- REALLY WANT
TO APPRECIATE IS THAT WELCOME
FOR IT TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO FIVE TO BE ABLE TO. ACTS
LIKE- AND IT IS NEEDED ACTION-
I WITH MANY THINGS IN THIS A IF
THE PUMP THAT WAS ONE OF. AND
THAT DURING V. ALL LEARNED CO.
AND QUICK THAT WE COULD DO OF-
FOR THOSE COUNTY IS THE HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTED A LOT BY IT
BEEN OVER. AND HAS COME SO MANY
FOLK THEY ARE. I'M AND FOR
THOSE COUNTIES THATSTILL NEEDS.
TO INTRODUCE BOTH SOME OF THAT
ARE. BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE
WORK THE CORE TO GET THOSE.
RIGHT THE IMPLEMENTED AREA-
WOULD RESPECTFULLY I YOUR I.
DON'T THINK IT AN INSULT. WORK
FOR A V. EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
MATHIS THOMAS THE CHAIR WE HAVE
ONE PERSON Q. ALL RIGHT. LINE
NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN THANK YOU.
AND AT THE TIME OF THIS YEAR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WILL MOVED
OPPOSITE I HAVE. NO OPPOSITION
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. ALL RIGHT
SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN PLUS PLUS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER INFLATION BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN. OF A EIGHT EIGHTY.
PLEASE ONE TO THEIR OWN. AND AT
THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE SHOWING UP. I THINK YOU
ARE PRETTY ME CLOSE THE LAW FOR
AB EIGHT EIGHTY SO. THAT'LL
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTION COME. THE STATE. THANK
YOU AND I WANT TO THANK- WITH
FOR SPEAKING I'M NOT WITH THE
MESS VIOLENCE KOBE RIGHT NOW-
THE NEW WERE UP. AND ONE THREE
WHY YOU WERE GETTING- CALL ON
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY WERE WITH
THE VIOLENT ACT THEY CAN GET A
SO IS REAL IMPORTANT I
COMPLETELY SAID THIS AND- ONE
THING I DO HAVE THAT IN THEIR
SYSTEM THAT THEY'D LIKE TO DO
THIS IT IS POSSIBLE WHICH I
AGREE BUT NO LATER THAN JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I
THINK THIS IS URGENT BECAUSE-
ABUSE HAPPENS AFTER FIVE PM AND
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER TAT SO TO
ME THIS IS SERGEANT AND A DAY
COULD BE MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
SOMEONE'S LIFE OR DEATH THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS.
PRICING NINE MISTER LINI MAKE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU TO THE WAY- TO
MISTER. POOL A- HOW DO. IT IS
TO DEFY- THIS BILL DOES SAY
THAT IT NEEDS BE. PROMINENT
LOCATED ON THE WEB. SO IT IS
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO FILE. AND TO
MISS DAVIES POINT- I DID
INTRODUCED THIS BILL LAST YEAR-
IN THE SENATE. AND DIVE. IT
DIDN'T- GET THROUGH- WE I
BELIEVE IT'S URGENT AS WELL.
AND TO THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ARE DOING THIS HOPEFULLY. THE
OTHER TWENTY WILL- GET GOING
BEFORE. THE LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINE IF THIS BECOMES LAW.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION THIS. THE MOTION IS TO
PAY. TO APPROACH. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STAY. HI STONE I
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE CHAU.
CHARGE DAVIES. DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. HI CONSOLES I HOLDEN.
KALRA. HOWEVER I CAN. AYE KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES. I RACE I.
THE BILL IS A- RIGHT THAT TAKES
US TO A NUMBER FOR EIGHT NINE
THIRTY SERVING THANK YOU VERY
MR CHIU MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BIKE THE CA SIX
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN OUR IS AND
I'M AND YOU BY THE WAY TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOUR WERE ON
THAT EIGHTY NINE TO AUTHOR. A
PREVAILED PARTY TO RECOVER FEES
FOR CLAIM ARISING FROM POOR
MARK AND SUBSEQUENTLY
UNDERGROUND. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE CPUC IN A AND INVEST AND P.
E. P. GENIES LOOK AND MARK
PROGRAM THE CPC WERE DETERMINED
THAT P. FONG. OF TWO ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND ONE
AND SEVEN RECORDS THESE
MARKINGS ARE USED BY CREWS TO
EXACTLY WHERE THEIR DANGEROUS
UNDERGROUND PIPELINES ARE
LOCATED THE CPC ALSO REPORTED
SIXTY SEVEN INSTANCES OF DAMAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A RESULT OF
THESE FALSIFIED RECORDS. THE
CPC ULTIMATELY FIND P. JEANNIE
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THESE VIOLATIONS
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE PC
INVESTIGATION IT WAS DETERMINED
THAT PG&E WOULD LEVERAGE ITS
LEGAL RESOURCES TO FILE CLAIMS
AGAINST LESS RESOURCEFUL
EXCAVATIONS EXCAVATION
CONTRACTORS THE INVESTIGATION
FOUND THAT AT LEAST ON ONE
OCCASION PG&E CREATED A WAR
ROOM WITH THE SOLE INTENT TO
MAXIMIZE. THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
AGAINST CONTRACTORS EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY WILL MAKE UTILITY
COMPANIES THINK TWICE BEFORE
FIRING OFF FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS
IT'LL FORCE. THEM TO INCREASE
THE ACCURACY. OTHER UNDERGROUND
IN. LOOK PROBE IN C. FOR WORK.
AND PUBLIC THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I RESPECT REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IS
MISTER STEVE WARD VICE
PRESIDENT OF PAVEMENT RECYCLING
SYSTEMS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
MISTER GERALD MASSES FOR THE
MASSES LAW FIRM LOCATED IN
TUSTIN. RIGHT THANK YOU I DO
HAVE MISTER IN THIS MOSES AS
SUPPORT QUICKNESS. MISTER.
THANK YOU SHERMAN STONE ENTRY
NUMBER- AGAIN I AM STEVE WAR
WITH PAPER RECYCLING SYSTEM-
THE BEST I CAN DO IS OF IT'S
IMPORTANT BUDGET. IS. CONVEY A
STORY FROM MY BEFORE I WITH
PAPERS. ON THE SMALL COME- BUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE. IN EMPLOYEES-
NOT CHIU AMOUNT OF RESOURCE- ON
STATE HIGHWAY PER. IN TWENTY
NINE PALMS FOR CALTRANS- WE
COMPLETED THE FOR MILLION.
ABOUT A YEAR AFTER THE PRODUCT
WAS DONE- ARE YOU SEE A BILL
FROM CAL EDISON FOR FIVE
DOLLARS FOR THEIR CLAIM THAT WE
HAD STRUCK ONE OF THE BALL- I
REQUEST PHOTOS OF THE DAM. IT
WAS ALL ARE QUICKNESS DID NOT
DO IT. AND I DECLINE TO PAY THE
DOLLARS DOLLARS A KNEW I RIGHT.
BUT IT COST US FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO WIN A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR CASE- CONTRACTORS NOW
HAVE LEARNED. ON THESE PLANES
YOU JUST PAY THEM THAT'S A
BUSINESS DECISION BECAUSE IT
WILL COST YOU MORE. BUT WHEN
YOU EVEN THOUGH YOU KNOW YOU'RE
RIGHT- IT MY FEELING AFTER
FORTY YEARS IN THIS BUSINESS IS
THAT ALL OF THE UTILITIES HAVE
DECIDED. THAT HEY WE JUST TORN
FRAMES OUT THERE THEY WILL
CREATE IT RATHER THAN FIGHT IT
BECAUSE IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE TO
FIGHT IT. OUT EVEN THE LARGER
COMPANIES IT'S JUST A BUSINESS-
WHY SPEND FORTY THOUSAND WHEN A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR CASE. I
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR YOUR
MUCH AND DESERT IS. A HUGE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. ON
PUBLIC WORKS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MOSES. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M GERALD
HOUSES ON THE MANAGING PARTNER
THE MOUSE'S LAW FIRM IN TUSTIN
CALIFORNIA ALSO MEMBER OF THE-
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND OUR PRACTICES
PREDOMINATELY RELATED TO THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY- INCLUDED
IT ATTORNEY'S FEES HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN MANY OTHERS
STATUTES ALL WITH. THE PURPOSE
AND POLICY OF REDUCING
LITIGATION PARTICULARLY
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION- OTHER
STATUTES THAT EXIST TODAY SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA FALSE CLAIMS
ACT IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE- IT
PROVIDES PARTIES WITH THE
ABILITY TO. RECOVER ATTORNEYS
FEES AND ACTUALLY IN THAT CASE
ON BOTH SIDES THE CONTRACTOR
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
CLAIM FILE WHICH IS ACCURATE
AND TRUTHFUL THAT THE I'S ARE
DOTTED AND THE CROSS AS WELL AS
THE AGENCY AND CRY IN
PROSECUTING A FALSE CLAIM
ACTION NEEDS TO. TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT BECAUSE WHOEVER
PREVAILS AND THAT AND IF IS
FOUND ON THE PART OF THE AGENCY
THAT IT'S A FRIVOLOUS CLAIM
ATTORNEYS FEES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE PAID- PROMPT PAYMENT
STATUTES EXIST IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE IN THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE AGAIN
WHEN PAYMENT IS MADE BY AN
HONOR TO A GENERAL CONTRACTOR
THAT PAYMENT HAS TO BE TURNED
AROUND. FOR UNDISPUTED WORK- TO
THE SUBCONTRACTOR AND IF NOT
THERE IS A RECOVERY FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES AND LITIGATION
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT PROMOTES THE
POLICY NOT ONLY REDUCING
LITIGATION BUT HAVING PEOPLE
PAY TIMELY HAVERHILL ALSO. OKAY
AND THE OTHER. WELL AND I WORK
I AM SO THERE'S A I'M SUCH AS A
MINISTER- I THINK I THINK THERE
IS ON I'M SORRY PAUSING- BUT I
DIDN'T KNOW. IN CALIFORNIA
CLEAVES WAS A CO FROM COMMITTEE
NOT NO- IN ANY OF THE- I WOULD
THANK ALL THAT I WILL CONCLUDE-
SOMEBODY BRIEFLY HERE. AGAIN
THE ANTI STATUTES. BUT
DISCLOSURE MADE LIKE TO YELL
FOR SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC
INTEREST MOTIONS ARE FILED IN
THAT AND THERE ARE PROVISIONS
FOR ATTORNEYS FEES SO WHAT ALL
THESE STATUTES DEALING WITH AB
NINE THIRTY. PROPOSES TO DO IS
TO HELP PEOPLE EVALUATE THEIR
CLAIMS EARLY ON ESPECIALLY
PARTIES AND ATTORNEYS THAT WANT
TO BE POTENTIAL LITIGANTS AND
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE RISK. OF
HAVING TO PAY THE OTHER IT
SIDE'S ATTORNEYS' FEES NOW THAT
DOESN'T EXIST SAYS MR WARD-
EXPLAINED IN HIS EXAMPLE-
LOSSES CAN BE FILED FRIVOLOUSLY
JUST TO GET A NUISANCE VALUE
SETTLEMENTS AND I CAN TELL YOU
FROM PERSONAL. EXPERIENCE WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE THAT ALSO WHERE
I'VE HAD A CLIENT SUED AND
THEY'VE PAID A NUISANCE
SETTLEMENT RATHER THAN DEFENDED
ON THE MERITS FOR WE WOULD
LIKELY WIN. SO AB NINE THIRTY
THE ATTORNEY FEE PROVISION IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER STATUTES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING FOR ATTORNEYS FEES- THE
UNDERLYING POLICIES THAT WILL
REDUCE LITIGATION. AND AS- MR
LEVINE SO APTLY SAID IT ALSO
PROMOTES SAFETY WITH MORE
ACCURATE ARKINGS AND- TAKING
PLACE RATHER THAN LITIGATION
OCCURRING SO- MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION.
RESEARCHERS HARLEM SIGN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS AMENDED WANT TO
THANK MR LEVINE AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
AMERICANS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT S THERE OPERATOR OPEN
THE LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINE THIRTY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THREE ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR
WERE GATHERING THEIR NUMBER NOW.
MY NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS SKIPPED ON THE HALF OF
THE AMERICAN SUBCONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND FULL SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THE FIRST WITNESS-
WITH CASE HISTORY. PROVES THE
POINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT
THIS TIME IS THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE ONE OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED ZACHARY LEARY FROM
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SACRILEGE SECTOR-LIMóN
CERTIFICATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY. WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS OVERLY BROAD MARKET-
REASONABLE SIDE BOARDS RELATED
TO THE AMOUNT OF ATTORNEY'S BE.
A PARTY MUST PAY WE APPRECIATE-
THE AUTHOR AND- COMMITTEE STOPS
WORK ON THIS AND THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTING THAT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND AS A RESULT
WITH- WILL BE REMOVING.
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
OPERATE COULD OPEN THE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION FOR A. B. NINE
THIRTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB NINE THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
THREE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE I
THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES FOR AB NINE THIRTY. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEE NONE MR LEVINE YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANKS VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. DO
OF A MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK
YOU MR HOLDER FOR THE SECOND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE HI
STONE I GALLAGHER CHOW CHOW I
CHOOSE DAVIS DAVIES NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI RES I. SIX
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU RIGHT LET'S MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB THIRTY
FIVE MR CHAU.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. I
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING US
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS- THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE DUTIES
REQUIRED BY AB THIRTY FIVE DOES
NOT INADVERTENTLY IMPACT ANY
EXISTING RIGHTS OR REMEDIES. AB
THIRTY FIVE WOULD RECALL
REQUIRES SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
TO DISCLOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE A POLICY IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION THAT COULD LEAD.
TO PHYSICAL HARM. HAS
VERIFIABLE IN AUTHENTIC CONTENT
AND PRACTICES TO DECEPTIVELY
MANIPULATE OR DISRUPT THE
BEHAVIOR OF USERS. SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS FORM AN INTEGRAL PART
OF HOW U. S. ADULTS CONSUME
NEWS. ACCORDING TO THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER IN 202053% OF
U. S. ADULTS GOT THEIR NEWS
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.
ALTERNATIVELY IS THE TO START
REPORTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT APPROXIMATELY 50% OF
PEOPLE SHARE A NEW STORY ONLY
TO FIND OUT LATER THAT THIS
NEWS STORY WAS FALSE.
RESEARCHERS AT UC SAN FRANCISCO
FOUND THAT AFTER FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED CHINESE
VIRUS ON TOP WHEN TALKING ABOUT
COVERT NINETEEN THE NUMBER OF
TWEAKS THAT USED THAT PHRASE
ROSE BY 8000310051% SINCE MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY VIOLENT
ATTACKS AGAINST THE ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
OUR COMMUNITY HAS SKYROCKETED
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
MISINFORMATION. CALIFORNIA SO
CONSUMERS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW THE FACTS OF WHAT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE DOING TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION. SOME MAJOR
PLATFORMS OF MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT IN COMMUNICATING WITH
THEIR USERS AND THE PUBLIC ON
THEIR EFFORTS IN COMBATING THE
SPREAD OF MYTHS MISINFORMATION.
HOWEVER IT'S NOT CLEAR IF ALL
PLATFORMS TO DOING THIS AS WELL
AB THIRTY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
THE PLATFORMS- MAKE THOSE
DISCLOSURES TO THEIR CONSUMERS
THE BILL DOES NOT DIRECT DIRECT
HOW PLATFORM SHOULD CURATE
THEIR CONTENT IT ONLY REQUIRES
THE PLATFORMS TO GIVE A
DISCLOSURE. AND MAKE IT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY COUNTY
COUNCIL OR CITY ATTORNEY WILL
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
THIS STATUTE. IF AFTER-RECEIVING THE NOTICE THE
PLATFORM DOESN'T POST A POLICY
THEY WILL BE SUBJECT TO A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY PENALTY.
AB THIRTY FIVE IS NOT ONEROUS-
REQUIREMENT ON PLATFORMS BUT IT
IT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL I BELIEVE- I HAVE A
WITNESS A PROFESSOR JOHN SIMS-
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED PROFESSOR JOHN
SIMS FROM MICK GEORGE LAW
SCHOOL AND SEVEN ATTACK ARE
FROM THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. PROFESSOR SIMS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH MISTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THIS IS
JOHN SIMS I'M EMERITUS
PROFESSOR. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
THE PACIFIC SURE SCHOOL OF LAW.
MY TESTIMONY TODAY IS AN
ESTIMATE. AN INDIVIDUAL- BUT
IT'S BACKGROUND I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT I WAS A MEMBER OF
THE LAW SCHOOL FACULTY. BETWEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. I FEEL THE
SPECIAL HAS BEEN CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW AND IN PARTICULAR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. YEAH IN MY VIEW NO
SUBSTANTIAL CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION CAN BE RAISED ABOUT SB
THIRTY FIVE. THE BILL DOES NOT
REGULATE SPEECH. IT'S A
CONSUMER PROTECTION STATUTE
THAT MERELY REQUIRES PROVIDERS
OF THE SERVICE FOR USERS ABOUT
AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE
MANNER IN WHICH THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM IS OPERATED. THE
MANY DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
AFFABLE TO THOSE PROVIDING
GOODS AND SERVICES AND FIRST
AMENDMENT LAW ACCEPTS THIS
EVERYDAY PROCESS OF REGULATION
WHICH PROTECT AGAINST FRAUD
EXPLOITATION AND OTHER INJURIES.
AB THIRTY FIVE IS LIKE A
REQUIREMENT THE ONE SELLING A
NEWSPAPER OR MAGAZINE. THE SALE
PRICE ON THE CVER OF THE FIRST
PAGE. SIMILARLY ONE SOME
SOFTWARE COULD BE REQUIRED TO
INFORM PURCHASERS ABOUT WHETHER
THERE'S A WARRANT. IN DEALING
WITH EXPRESSION PROTECTED BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LOBBY MORE
PRECISE THAN WHAT IS EXPECTED
FROM RUN OF THE MILL
LEGISLATION. NOW THIS BILL IS
QUITE DETAILED. I AND MOREOVER
IT DOESN'T REGULATE THE CONTENT
OF SPEECH AT ALL. NOR DOES IT
EVEN TOUCH UPON THE TIME PLACE
AND MANNER OF EXPRESSION. THE
FIRST AMENDMENT DOES NOT
PREVENT CONSUMER PROTECTION
DISCLOSURES OF THESE PIPES AND
I AM CONFIDENT THAT AB THIRTY
FIVE WOULD EASILY SURVIVE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT CHALLENGE IF
ANYONE WOULD RAISE SUCH AN
ISSUE. AND IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THOSE OF COURSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CAR. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS TO BE
AN ATTACKER WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE THE
TOPIC OF MISINFORMATION HAVE
BEEN HOTLY DEBATED ISSUE FOR
SOMETIME NOW DATA SHOWS THAT
AMERICANS ROUTINELY RELY UPON
NEWS GET OF MEDIA PLATFORMS
THIS NEW FORMAT SOCIAL MEDIA BE
POSTING. ALLOWS AND ENCOURAGES
ALL NEW STORY TO REACH MATH
AUDIENCE TOPIC NEW THE RICH IN
A ELECTION NEWS THAT NOW BY THE
TEN WITH CONSEQUENCES IF IT
NEVER MADE OF HOW CO NINETEEN
EXPRESS THE NUMBER OF CASES
WHERE THE OF BY THE BUYER CAME
FROM NOW ONLY IF WE CAN R. K.
YOU CAN ITS BY IT BUT IT ALSO
LIKE A GROUP CRIME AGAINST EACH
AMERICAN. EIGHTY THREE IS AN
IMPORT FIRST TOWARD TACKLING
ISSUE AND THREE CENTS. OUR
THANK YOU. THANK OPERATOR YOU
NOW OVER THE FOR THOSE ON THE
LINE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE THEIR
NAY AFFILIATION AND IN OF FOR A
BI. THIRTY THE CHAIR LADIES AND-
IF YOU WISH SPEAK IT'S OF A DE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PER YOU WITH A
LINEUP. IN PLACE YOU BACK IN Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND THAT THIS WOMAN IS THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU I WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION. LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE WHO WANTED TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY FIVE. SHARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. WE DO
HAVE TO MENTION THAT MISTER
CHAIR ONE MOMENT THANK YOU.
WELCOME. JUST GETTING THE LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CLOSE COSTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES FOR THE V.
THIRTY FIVE. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
CHARLIE NICHOLAS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
AMOTION A SECOND MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE ARTS
COMMITTEE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHILD FIVE CHAO I'D SHOOT
DAVIES DAVIES NO GONZALEZ. HI
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI RES I. THE
BILL IS ABOUT THANK YOU I DO
NOT SEE MR CHIU DOOR MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SO WE'LL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB NINE HUNDRED
THAT'S RIGHT YES. ALL THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
TODAY PRESENT A. B. NINE ZERO
ZERO. THE BILL ANOTHER ROUTE
RIGHT. OPERATOR THE LINES. OPEN
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE NOT. I
THINK YOU SORT SORT OR IS THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME INTERFERENCE
BUT PLEASE CONTINUE AB NINE
HUNDRED WOULD REQUIRE
CHARITABLE TRUSTEES TO PROVIDE
NOTICE TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHEN A TERRIBLE TRUSTEE INTENDS
TO MOVE ALL OR SUBSTANTIALLY
ALL TERRIBLE ASSETS OWNED BY
THE TRUST. UNDER EXISTING LAWS
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TWENTY DAYS
BEFORE THE CORPORATION INTENDS
TO MOVE ALL OR SUBSTANTIALLY
ALL OF ITS ASSETS HOWEVER DUE
TO AN EXISTING INCONSISTENCY
WITHIN CALIFORNIA LAW
CHARITABLE TRUSTS HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO CIRCUMNAVIGATE TO
THIS SIMPLE SIMPLE NOTICE THAT
ALL OTHER NONPROFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE. AB NINE HUNDRED SIMPLY
FIX THE SYSTEM IF THIS FIXES
THIS INCONSISTENCY IN CURRENT
LAW AND ENSURES THAT TRUSTEES
ARE ACTING IN GOOD FAITH. HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE ANTHONY LIU
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL- FROM
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. THANK YOU MS
REYES I HAVE ONE PERSON
INDICATED FOR SUPPORT THAT IS
THE ANTHONY LIU FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ALTHOUGH I WILL NOTE
THAT THE HIGHLIGHT OF HIS
CAREER WAS SERVING AS A STAFFER
TO THIS COMMITTEE. MR LIVE.
OKAY MORE THAN ANYTHING- LET'S
JUMP MODEL- CLEAN. UP SORRY IF
YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING WOULD YOU
PLEASE PUT YOURSELF ON MUTE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR. MISTER LIU.
TESTIFYING ON AB A LITTLE BLIND
CHAIR. FIVE DOLLARS ONE MOMENT
THEY SHARED WE BRING OFF LINE
TO LET HIM KNOW WHAT TO TURN
BEAT THANK YOU. I FEEL LIKE. I
DON'T. I DON'T LIKE. IT MISTER
LOWER. I BELIEVE HE WAS GOING
TO BE A TO ANSWER TECH
QUESTIONS SURE SO IF YOU JUST
WILL TAKE AT THE HE WAS
THIRTEEN TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON
FROM LINES FOR WHO'S TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE HUNDRED.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IT
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR- NOW. THIS TIME
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
LISTED OPPOSITION. OPERATOR OF
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB NINE HUNDRED. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE HUNDRED.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ON LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB NINE HUNDRED. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO
ONE Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT C.
NINE WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THANK YOU MISTER
ISCHEMIC CLOSE. PERSPECTIVE YES
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
MOTION IS TO PASS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHAU TO. DAVIES
DAVIES I COULD. GONZALEZ I.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS AYE
REYES AYE. RIGHT THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AB FIVE FIVE SIX.
SO OUR ITEM NINE AB FIVE FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS FRATELLI FRAUD OCCURS
WHEN A DOCTOR THAT SPECIALIZES
IN ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE KNOWINGLY IMPLANTS A
PATIENT WITH A SPERM SAMPLE
THAT IS NOT THE ONE SELECTED
FROM THE DONOR BANK BUT INSTEAD
IS FROM THE DOCTOR HIMSELF.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA HAS
ENACTED STRICT LAWS AGAINST
THOSE PRACTICES AND LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH CHANGE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON THESE CRIMES FOR
THREE YEARS AFTER COMMISSION TO
ONE YEAR AFTER DISCOVERY TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB FIVE FIVE SIX
WHICH FOCUSES ON OTHER ASPECT
OF FERTILITY FRAUD. CHOOSING
THAT UTILIZE AND UNDERGO
ASSISTIVE REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE
CAN BE COSTLY. WITH SOME
TREATMENTS AND PROCEDURES BEING
SO COSTLY VICTIMS CAN BE HURT
FINANCIALLY AS SOME PARENTS.
USE THEIR ENTIRE LIFE SAVINGS
TO CONCEIVE A FAMILY. THROUGH
THIS METHOD AB FIVE FIVE SIX
WOULD PROVIDE VICTIMS WITH THE
ABILITY TO SEEK DAMAGES IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE ANOTHER AVENUE
FOR JUSTICE FOR THOSE VICTIMS.
APPLE PEPPERING TELEPHONICALLY
WITH ME TODAY HAVE SERRA LONDON
WITH THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. WHO WORKS IN THIS
FIELD. THANK YOU- MISTER CHAN
MEMBERS RESPECT THE REQUEST NOT
BUT- THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN. SO I HAVE ONE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT LISTED
SEVERAL LONDON FROM THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA THIS ONE ARE YOU
ONLINE. YES GOOD MORNING
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TERRA ONE
THEN I'M A PARTNER AT LIEFF
CABRASER HEIMANN AND BURNED IN
A LOCKER BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND I'M ON THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE FIVE
SIX. MY CAREER HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO SEEKING JUSTICE
FOR THE INJURED INCLUDING THOSE
WHO HAVE SUFFERED THAT
DEVASTATING LOSS OF THEIR
GENETIC MATERIAL INFERTILITY
INDUSTRY FAILURES. I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS LIAISON COUNSEL IN THE
CASE ARISING OUT OF THE LAB AND
BREEDER FAILURES THAT TOOK
PLACE AT THE PACIFIC FERTILITY
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MY CLIENTS ARE
AMONG THE NEARLY SIX HUNDRED
WOMEN AD FAMILIES WHO'VE
LEARNED THAT THE AG'S AND
EMBRYOS THAT THEY WERE ASSURED
WILL BE SAFELY STORED. THEY
WERE READY TO BECOME PARENTS.
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED. OR AT THAT
TO COMPROMISE. IT IS HARD TO
DESCRIBE THE SHOCK PAIN AND
GRIEF AMONG THOSE WHO LOSE
PIECES THEMSELVES INFERTILITY
INDUSTRY FAILURE IT IS EIGHT
YEARNING TO BECOME APPARENT
THAT BRING PEOPLE TO SPEAK OUT
FOR KELLY SERVICES. ANY
INDUSTRY IN HAS RAMPED UP ITS
MARKETING EFFORTS IN NEED THAT
THE MAN AND POLICY AGAINST
BIOLOGICAL CLOCK. THE PROCESS
INCLUDING PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY. WOMEN TAKE A
COCKTAIL OF MEDICATIONS UNDERGO
NEUMARKT LIGHTPATH PUBLIC EXAM.
INJECTIONS WITH FORMAL THAT
CUTS WELDING THE COMFORT AND
CAN LEAD TO SEVERE COMPLICATION.
THE PROSPECT OFTEN. AS AN
EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER AND
INDEED THE MAGNITUDE OF DESPAIR
AND ANXIETY DURING. IDEA IS
COMPARED BY PROFESSIONAL
SPEAKING A CANCER DIAGNOSIS. IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE FAMILY
PLANNING GOALS WOMEN OFTEN GO
TO MORE THAN ONE CYCLE ALL IN
THE EFFORT MAXIMIZE THEIR
CHANCES OF HAVING A BIOLOGICAL
CHILD OR BIOLOGICAL SIBLINGS.
AND OF COURSE ALL OF THE COMBAT
A SIGNIFICANT. ANYWHERE BETWEEN
FIFTEEN TO THIRTY THOUSAND
CRITICAL. UNFORTUNATELY THE
WOMEN AND FAMILIES TO PLACE
THEIR TRUST IN THE INDUSTRY TO
SAFEGUARD THEIR PRECIOUS
GENETIC MATERIAL HAVE BEEN
BETRAYED. I THINK ANYTHING
INVESTIGATION FOUND PATCHWORK
REGULATIONS AND SELF OVER QUITE
A LACK OF CLEAR CONSISTENT
STANDARDS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THERE HAVE BEEN TOO MANY
INSTANCES NOW FOR FREEZER
STORAGE EQUIPMENT AND NOW OF
COURSE NOT JUST DURING CORRECT
PERFECT GENETIC MATERIAL BUT
ALSO BACKSEAT- HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO HAVE FEEDBACK THAT WERE BOTH
KNOWN FOR THE COMPANIES AND
INEXPENSIVE FIX BUT NOT
RECALLED FIXED- WANTED. AND WE
HAVE ALSO SEEN IN CLICK INTO
ALONG ARE UP TO DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW SUCH. ARE ADEQUATE TO A
SHARP. CUSTOMER THAT ARE HAD
BEEN AND WITH KEPT STATE.
EXPERIENCE IS GATHERED. TO PACE
GOING THE I. PROCESS. BUT AND
HERE WE- IS THE- ALSO BY FAR TO
FAMILY. DONOR KIRKLAND A SIXTY
WEEK MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
KNOWINGLY. THE FIRM OVER.
SELECT BY THE PATIENT WITH THAT
OF ANOTHER. IT HAPPENED WITHOUT
THE PATIENT CAN AND SOMETIMES
EVEN IF WITH THE YOU A STAMP OF
THEIR- IN THE PROCESS. THE FACT
THAT WOMEN UNDERGO A COOLING
PROPERTY. MUST PLACE FULL TRUST
IN THAT AND YET EIGHT RISK OF
BEING THE BY THE VERY PEAK THEY
PLAY THEIR TRUST IN. IF NOTHING
SHORT OF ABHORRENT. MANY OF
THESE PROBLEMS JUST DO NOT COME
LIGHT BECAUSE FOURTH CLAUSES
THAT DELAY OR ELIMINATE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MANY
FERTILITY COMPANIES ARE PRIVATE
BUSINESS ENTITIES THAT OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM
THEY DO NOT EVEN HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO CARRY A MINIMUM
LEVEL OF INSURANCE. ALL OF
THESE PROBLEMS HIGHLIGHT HOW
THE INDUSTRY IS RIPE FOR FRAUD
AND ABUSE. AB FIVE FIVE SIX
RECOGNIZES THAT THE LITTLE
REMEDIES ARE NEEDED FOR THE
DEVASTATING HIGHLY PERSONAL AND
EMOTIONAL LOSSES. CAUSED BY
DONOR BROADBAND FACILITY
INDUSTRY FAILURE. MEASURES LIKE.
FIVE FIVE OUR CRITICAL DEJECTED
AND PUBLICLY ACCOUNT. FOR AND
WE SUPPORT THE DELTA CREDIT
STEP TOWARD IMPROVING IN THIS.
I AM HAVE TO BE A RESOURCE AS
THE LARGEST LOOK AT ENACT
MARCOM. SOLUTIONS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
NAME ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
FOR AB FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACKINTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE FIVE SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT
THE CHAIR. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE MAKES YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVED
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED. OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE FIVE SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF
AB FIVE FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AND THAT
THIS THOMAS THE CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES FOR AB FIVE FIVE SIX OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. RIGHT
SEEING NONE OF TAKE A MOTION.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE PATHS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. I'M SORRY
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THEN
RESPECT THEIR ACOSTA. THANK YOU.
SORRY ABOUT THAT CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER HI CHAU
CHOW I CHIU. CHU I DAVE. DAVIES
I GONZALEZ RIGHT AND I HOLD.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. HI NO MAIENSCHEIN I
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RIESS. THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT WILL MOVE TO OUR FINAL
ITEM ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE MISTER TO. ONE IS
THE CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES WE ALL
KNOW HOW MUCH THIS PANDEMIC IS
INTERRUPTED ALL ASPECTS OF OUR
LIVES. FOR SOME THIS IS MEANT
PUTTING THE MOMENTOUS OCCASION
OF A MARRIAGE CEREMONY ON HOLD.
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALLOWING MARRIAGE LICENSES TO
BE ISSUED AND MARRIAGES
SOLEMNISED. REMOTELY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. AND COUNTIES
THAT HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
THIS NEW AUTHORITY REMOTE
LICENSING AND MARRIAGE HAS BEEN
VERY POPULAR. I BILL AB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE WOULD MAKE THIS
OPTION AVAILABLE FOR ANOTHER
TWO YEARS WHILE COUNTY CLERK'S
CONTINUE. TO EXPLORE BEST
PRACTICES WITH AN EYE TOWARD
MAKING THIS PERMANENTLY
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TAKING TIME OFF WORK TO WAIT IN
LINE AT THE CLERK'S OFFICE IS
NOT ALWAYS EASY TO DO. THE
OPTION TO REMOTELY INTERFACE
WITH THE CLERK MAYBE IN A
SUBSIDY. PARTICULARLY FOR
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE TO GET TIME
OFF DURING REGULAR BUSINESS
HOURS. A SMALL CHANGE ALIGN THE
SERVICES OF CLARK'S WITH THE
TECHNOLOGICAL CAPABILITIES AND
THE EXPECTATIONS OF EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS. IS A GOOD STEP
TOWARD ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS WITHOUT LIKE TO OPEN UP
TO A WITNESS. RIGHT THANK YOU
MR CHIU WE DO HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES LISTED MATT
SILVERLINK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. ON THE
TELEPHONE AND THEN LUIS TREMONT
FOR THE INTERIM ASSISTANT
COUNTY CLERK AND RECORDER FROM
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. MR
SILVERMAN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT FIVE
RULING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WORKS
ALEXION OFFICIALS YUP SPONSORED
THE BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT THE LIVER TISSUE. UP FOR
AT FOR CARRYING IMPORTANT
MEASURE WHICH CAME TO LIGHT AS
A RESULT THE PANDEMIC THE
CHANGE SO MUCH. AND HOW WE
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER MORE
SPECIFICALLY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SERVE THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AND OFFER
CRITICAL PUBLIC RESOURCES. AB
FIVE EIGHTY THREE THE ENTIRE OF
THE YEAR OF ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE FOR THE COUNTY TO
EVOLVE AND ADAPT IT. TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC DURING
THE STAY AT HOME ORDER. I'M NOT
A WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
MANY MONTHS WE RECEIVED
EXTREMELY POSITIVE FEEDBACK OF
OUR CUSTOMERS WHO APPRECIATE
THE ACT THAT. ANY OPTION IF
IT'S EITHER THE FUTURE. EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY THREE WILL ALLOW
COUNTY TO CONTINUE TO OFFER
THESE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
REMOTELY AND ELECTRONICALLY.
WHICH WE GREATLY APPRECIATE AND
HIGHLY RECOMMEND. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAURA CHEVRON AND I'M THE
INTERMITTENT COUNTY CLERK
RECORDER FOR THE COUNTER
SACKLER I'M ALSO HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS THE SPONSOR
OF AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE. CA CEO
IS PROUD AND GRATEFUL TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIR TO
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WHO WISHED
MERRY WITH A STATEMENT CONVENE
AN OPTION TO OBTAIN A COMPLETE
MARRIAGE LICENSES
ELECTRONICALLY AND HAVE THEIR
UNIONS SOLEMNISED LOWLY THREE
INTERACTIVE VIDEO TECHNOLOGY.
THE COVERED NINETEEN PENNED.
AND THE SUBJECT VISITS TEST
CHANGE AND OTHER AND SAFETY
MANDATES UNDER TAKEN. IN
RESPONSE TO IT HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO COMPLY WITH
EXISTING LAW AND APPEAR IN
PERSON IN CONNECTION. WITH
VARIOUS STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO
ADMINISTER A VALID AND LEGAL
MARRIAGE. AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
EXPLORES. COLLATES THEM
MORALIZING CODE THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT HAVE BEEN
EMPLOYED BY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
DURING THE PAST YEAR WITH
REGARD TO REMOTE AND LIKE
TRONIC ISSUANCE OF MARRIAGE
LICENSES AND SOLEMNIZATION
CEREMONIES THROUGH LIVE
INTERACTIVE VIDEO TECHNOLOGY.
THE FRAMEWORK PROPOSED BY
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY THREE. IS
THE PRODUCT OF MONTHS OF
DISCUSSION TROUBLESHOOTING AND
PROBLEM SOLVING OVER THE COURSE
OF THIS CHALLENGING HERE. AS
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF ALL TO
MEET THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. WE HAVE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION TO IMPROVING CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS. AFTER
THIS LAST YEAR WE ARE CERTAIN
THAT MODERNIZING. THIS PROCESS
WHEN NEEDED. IT'S POSSIBLE AND
WE URGE YOU TO ALLOW COUNTIES
TO CONTINUE SERVING THE PUBLIC.
CA CEO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE US THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT IF
THE CHAIR. MY NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER NUMBERS KAREN
LYING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THIS MORNING THINKING
OF. AND AT THIS TIME AT THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THINKS YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED. BUT
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. POINT ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. AT
THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO MONEY Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES
FOR AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE AND I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MS GONZALEZ. SO I AM
MY QUESTION IS LIKE WHY AREN'T
WE JUST MAKING THIS PERMANENT.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION- THAT
WAS SOMETHING WE HAD BEEN
THINKING ABOUT INITIALLY- WE'VE
BEEN ASKED BY THE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS THAT OVERSEE THIS FOR
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS GOES WELL DURING
A NON PANDEMIC SETTING. BEFORE
COMING BACK AND ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD MY INITIAL INTENT WAS
TO DO THIS- PERMANENTLY BUT I
RESPECT TO- THE OFFICIALS ARE
ARE CONDUCTING THIS THEY WANNA
MAKE SURE THEY GET IT RIGHT
BEFORE THEY- ASK FOR. IT SO WE
SHOULD THINK OF THIS MORE IS
JUST A NORMAL KIND OF SUNSET
BUT WE'RE PLANNING TO COME BACK
AND THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT BUT
NOT JUST LIKE A PROGRAM FOR
THIS TYPE CORRECT THE INTENSE
AS A AS I SAID IS TO MAKE THIS
PERMANENT BUT- BUT WE HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO. MOTIONS NO THERE'S NO
EMOTION I'M OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE DO A MOTION
AND A SECOND MISS DAVIES. THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS. AFFORD ADVERSELY
MY BACKGROUND OF- TUNING TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF- WEDDING PLANNING.
I HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS ALL
LAST YEAR. AND SO- IT REALLY
WAS- YOU KNOW. HELPFUL WHEN
THEY FINALLY STARTED DOING THIS
YOU HAVE A LOT OF. WE HAVE A
LOT OF COUPLES THAT OUR
MILITARY THAT NEED TO GET
MARRIED THAT NEED TO LEAVE- I
HAD A LOT OF COUPLES THAT WERE
DESTINATION THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE UNABLE TO COME IN THERE
AND ALSO A LOT OF THE VERY
COMFORTABLE. BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO GET UP. WITH
COVERT. YOU HAVE TO GO IN
PERSON- ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAD.
ON FAMILY- ELDER FAMILY SO.
AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY COULD BE MOVED FORWARD- I
THINK AGAIN YOU HAVE A BACKLOG
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE EFFICIENT. ANDY SAVING A LOT
OF TIME AND I'D LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON IT. HAPPY FOR THAT
AND CERTAINLY GIVE YOUR
EXPERTISE APPRECIATE THAT.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CIGNA MISTER CHAIRMAN CLOSE
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE
I THINK ALL OF US AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS WE KNOW THAT
OFFICIATING WEDDINGS THIS IS
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THEIR
FAVORITE ASPECTS OF OUR JOB AND
SOMETHING THAT BRINGS
INCREDIBLE JOY TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL IS A STEP
WE CAN TAKE TO MAKE GOVERNMENT
SERVICES MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
SPREAD THE LOVE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS CULTURAL PLEASE. STONE HI
STONE I GALLAGHER. AYE
GALLAGHER AYE CHOW. CHOW I CHIU
PART TO ITV'S. DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. CONSULTS AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN. MENTION
IRIS. THANK YOU THAT BILL IS
OUT ALL OF THE BUSINESS IS
COMPLETE ALL THE BILLS AND THE
RULES ARE ADOPTED SO LET'S NOW
GO THROUGH THE LIST OF ALL THE
BILLS STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA AND LET MEMBERS ADD ON
SO CONSENT AGENDA. TO AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN. FIVE
ALL RIGHT THANK ITEM NUMBER THE
COMMITTEE CALL THE UPS OF MY.
TWO FIVE TWO I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I
MAIENSCHEIN MANGE I RIGHT ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB SO ONE SIX PLANET
CALL THE OPTIMUM CHIU CHU I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MANGE I. READ ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN LEVINE CALL THE MEMBERS
TO CHOI I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I MAY.
MAIN CHENNAI. I AM NUMBER FOUR
AB NINTH LIVE CALLED UPS A
MEMBER. GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER
NO. CHU I KILEY MAY. MAIN CHINA.
I REMEMBER FIVE AB EIGHT FIFTY
ROMA. TO CHIU I KILEY MANGE.
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT. I REMEMBER
SIX AB TWO ONE EIGHT WARD. TWO
FIVE TO OUR MAIENSCHEIN MAIN
CHINA. FOR OVER SEVEN A. B.
FIVE CHAU. GALLAGHER. TWO FIVE
TWO I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
REMEMBER EIGHT AB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE CHIU REYES. K. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB FIVE FIVE SIX
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. I REMEMBER
TEN AB NINE HUNDRED RADIUS
GALLAGHER. NO GALLAGHER NO CHIU
CHUGAI. CORRECT THANK YOU WILL
GIVE IT A FEW MORE MINUTES FOR
MISERY AS HE HAS WON ITEM IT
SOUNDED TO STILL BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON.
FOR A ITEM NUMBER FOR
THERE'S A OF THE CHAIN. AB
NINE. DAVIES NO VOTE. AT A NO
VOTE TO A NON VOTING THAT FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT
RIGHT RIGHT.
REYES.
YEAH. OKAY.
ALL.
NUMBER. THREE ONE. MARK
TWAIN. YEAH GOOD.
THIS CALL.
YEAH RIGHT. SO WE HAVE TO ITEMS
THAT STILL NEED TO BE
POTENTIALLY VOTED ON SO ITEM
NUMBER. EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. REYES YES I. N. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB FIVE FIVE SIX
MAIENSCHEIN RACE. RAYSIDE GREAT
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE ARE
THE GERMANS. YEAH.